the broderick kids make a rare public
appearance for their parents big night
sarah jessica parker and hubby matthew
broderick made it a family affair for
the opening night of their new broadway
show plaza suite i think it's deeply
meaningful to us because we've waited a
long time and when i say we i mean
a small but mighty cast a crew every
single person
put a pin in this and every single
person came back here is 19 year old
james in the middle rocking a black
student's high in sjp's 12 year old twin
daughters marion wearing a blush dress
with a necklace and tabitha on the right
sporting a black ensemble it was just
magical now the kids are known to be
very private but sjp shared a rare photo
of james to give him a big 19th birthday
shout out on instagram in october saying
quote on this one it's bittersweet not
to be with him i wish him the most
happiest of birthdays our scorpio our
october baby rjw happy birthday balloons
candles hoping every birthday wish to
come true kisses mama
and just one month earlier she posted
pics like a proud mama of her three kids
going off to school
writing quote in the span of seven days
one crosses the threshold into his
freshman year of college the other two
into the seventh grade it's been
thrilling
let's rewind back to 2014 when parker
tells e.t her daughter's experience
walking around in her heels loretta's
just slightly more timid in her
movements but tabitha is clickity click
click click click i'm running in heels
sometimes talk about a true
mother-daughter moment with her twins
wanting to be just like their mama sjp
even opened up to vogue in february
about her iconic looks and mentions her
daughter understanding fame
i showed it to my daughters which i
never do anything like that you know
magazines aren't as much a part of their
life as
as might have been it when i was their
age you know i was like girls i have to
show you something and i pulled it out
and my both my daughter's hands went to
their mouths and they were like
mama
you're on the cover of vogue
i didn't know that they were aware of
them i was so tickled by
how it was so
innocent and unknowing and
not ruined the sex and the city star
also revealed to e.t in 2016 how one of
her daughters is trying to follow in
mom's footsteps i did hear the other day
that my daughter had some strange
conversation apparently one of my
daughters is
plotting to take over
i just learned this from somebody else
that she has designs so to speak on um
running as she says mama's company um
but that's just because i think she
really likes um
i think she really likes being bossy no
i think she likes organizing things and
and kind of putting things into action
and um so i think
obviously i if i walk down the stairs or
they see me getting dressed they have
opinions about what i'm wearing
um but they don't
they don't offer up design ideas yet i'm
sure that's all
moments away from happening